all right the first friendship is Shrek
and a potato
shrike'd oh if I can't figure this out
then how the hell is young children
gonna forget is that how I open it
Oh feels nice
not really disgusting I now realize that
my parents have protected me from this
all these years there's a reason why I
never finger-painting we need we need a
little bit of Shrek in there so let's
get the green ah that's the yellow it
looks like snot hmm get a good click in
there get Shrek this so far I love
it it's great don't judge it it's it's
an art in progress
all right it's like no matter how hard I
try it it looks like a three-year-old in
it this is the saddest thing ever
let's get that ding a ling ding dong in
there
damn damn strict balls yeah just cuz it
looks like a kid drew it it's so
disturbing okay let's get potato in
there
which finger have I not used all right
oh I mean I'm really starting to
regret this idea because what the
is this it's so disgusting oh how could
I forget
the lips I need to use my thumb for this
money okay just dip dip gently for the
nips
now those have some goddamn nice potato
nips true art Shrek a dough that ship
assailed okay someone suggested next
ship is me and my fingers what a great
ship I'll be orange I guess with a
little bit of red that's getting colored
right I just realized I just drew
something completely different
thank you it's pretty awesome
self-portrait
Dasha let's not forget about my
headphones let's not forget about my
nips am I doing with my life now
let's move on to my fingers I guess I
can just do like all the kids to do yeah
let me do that oh guys it's so nasty I'm
not okay with this
oh god I'm stuck help help
alright so now we're just gonna make a
fingerprint
Wow look at that I thought it would look
cool why do I have four fingers yeah
might sound Edgar
which color do you want to be that I
don't have pink brooch how with what how
do you know hey I'm just fulfilling
people's fantasies you basically look
like you're doing something with the
Smurfs I can't make it look like a dog I
don't know we have time for one more
the ultimate ship dan and Phil I'm
starting to master the technique a
little bit I gotta sing with great art
comes great responsibility not to draw a
shitty finery I think this is probably
the first finger-painted fan art
friendships it must be I mean no one not
young is that weird and twisted yeah
that looks great this really does belong
in an art museum they're flying above
the ocean and making love it's beautiful
and here are all the weirdos
that ship them together every goddamn
time there you are
this is you you're part of this they're
so happy it's art you can interpret it
the way you want it's beautiful TIPA
sailed
I feel like I want to do one more with
Shrek II I'm gonna use three three
finger strike so this is Shrek and trick
someone sue what's the problem baby
what's the problem man oh now maybe
yummy Shrek Shrek think about it or any
time I think about it can't stop and buy
it I ship them harder than him than an
air cargo
oh no I smudged out the nipples damn it
all right that was that was set I'm
gonna clean up now alright Prez that was
the art of fine art finger painting so
let's review our art we have Shrek and
potato beautiful we have me and my
fingers beautiful mites and Ed Gary what
the awful it really does belong in
a museum Ganon feel in front of
fans nothing weird and finally my
favorite Shrek in Shrek looks ugh I like
the texture it's very very very
beautiful
leave a like in a comment for a chance
for you to win this beautiful art book
it will probably be worth thousands and
also remember to submit your fan fiction
fan art with you finger painting use the
hashtag hashtag finger peds
yeah that's good maybe like me enjoy
this video Bros and if you want more
blue the heart of fan art and I will see
you bros as always in the next one stay
awesome bros
Pedro 15 I wanna be I wanna be as
realistic as possible so let's go for
realism that's what I would describe my
art style ass really